plus pour finir moi je comme j accepte
les compliments quand je suis des fois
je suis dans mon camion il flotte j'ai
pas le moral je vois plein de gens qui
font des compliments je suis content ça
va du bien ne sommes pas dit comme ça on
décide de venir à la télé ça va avec les
insultes moi j'aimerais qu'il dealait
m'insulter insulté moi mais ce sera
qu'une fois et après ce sera bloqué moi
je voulais même pas qu'on en parle on en
a parlé c'est bien en plus qu'il ya la
raison à la raison parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui en souffrent plus
que nous moi je vais vous dire quand ils
m'ont insulté je m'en fous mais alors
comme de l'an 40 g ces abrutis c'est ma
dernière année je vais de bloquer demain
je m'en fous complètement
en tout je prends le mag et jouer tu
préfères tu prends le négatif aussi avec
alors on a pris beaucoup de trucs sur
camélia jordana ya un mois je me suis
pris sur camélia le plus souvent
reproché alors qu'on me voie puisque
vous avez on va dire au tsv york est ce
que vous reprochez on m'a reproché
d'être d'être que dans un sens c'est de
dire que finalement parce que l étaient
pas des cités des cités elle n'avait pas
le droit de parler et les gens m'ont dit
c'est pas parce qu'elle vient pas des
cités qui a le droit de parler on m'a
reproché qu'on est tous tombés dessus
tous ensemble mais qu'il n'y avait pas
de contre-pouvoir à part un peu kelly
mais moi ce que je disais c'était le
massacre dont elle parlait des cités et
castaner monsieur castaner qui veut
aller faire un débat avec elle en télé
c'est sur ça que j'ai trouvé lunaire est
une fois de plus moi je vous le dis je
suppute dans les cités donc je pouvais
aussi me terrière dont j'étais pas
obligé de partir dans un joli ou qu'on
perd aucun média ghsr claude son avis on
n'a pas dit qu'elle devait pas d'arrêt
sur la vie nous donne notre avis surtout
ici voilà c'est tout mais après qu'elles
demandent un débat intérieur
là on marche on s'est tous serré on en a
parlé après on n'a jamais nié qu'il n'y
avait pas de violences policières dans
les quartiers on ne l'a jamais nier on
l'a dit sans mentir et moi on a dit on a
préféré les missions avec des jeunes de
banlieues qui souffrent vraiment
d'abord de certaines pratiques de police
et fritons ce camélia jordana qui va
être enfin sa filleule de l'intérieur
qui va lui dire les plus âgés fait la
nouvelle star et je connais doit bâtir
lui l'huile sur le feu c'est facile
manoukian mais quand tu invites pas dans
les cités c'est facile de parler comme
ça je me répète moi cet après midi mon
souci ce n'était pas de savoir si
l'ascenseur et marche ce n'était pas de
savoir s'il y avait un tramway ou quoi
c'était le filtre de la piscine
gonflable qui sait encrassé il a fallu
que j'aille au magasin h&m piscine moi
je suis fier je suis parti à lille en
croisant votre machine
je suis parti à 50 bord de parler je
suis pas obligé moi de venir et de
violet comme ça pour les sites et mobile
très bien